yep that's me you're probably wondering
how I ended up here let's take a step
back my name is Eric and I grew up here
birthplace of the Croy's sparkling water
seltzer is in my blood so today I'm
gonna try as many flavors as I can it's
a lot of seltzer to try so I'm gonna
have some friends help me out and select
our favorites after I've tried them all
we're gonna combine all seventy to make
the world's first mega seltzer
first up holder my whole life and then
David somebody who loved polar I don't
like to do Seltzer with straws I think
you lose the carbonation in the straw
and the way to your mouth yeah that's
good I'm into that
I'm eating Seltzer Kalash up next hails
how are you related to the company
second cousin candidate I wish I could
say I was like the CEO and owner but I
guess no profit from how many else else
our waters are sold
I wonder what intern was like okay I
have an idea a coffee flavored water I
mean it's not bad it's not bad not bad
it's not bad I'm kind of mad about that
it tastes a little bit like when you
have consumed an iced coffee and like
that ice is melted and it's just like a
watery flavor down at the bottom that's
a little bit what it tastes like
up next bubbly bubbly loosely no I think
it's bubbly it says no calories no
sweeteners all smiles and as a woman I
find that offensive because I don't like
anybody telling me to smile especially
not myself sir I'm just trying to hold
back so many verses yeah you probably
it's probably gonna be really unpleasant
coming out of your mouth and out of your
butt later I think Michael Buble is a
brand ambassador for this I mean he
should be if he isn't they're idiots
I mean smooth jazz smooth sparkly water
jazz musician doesn't he play like the
jazz clarinet or something or no am I
getting any views of someone Kenny G I'm
doing an appendage next up is spindrift
this is made with real fruit as opposed
to the essence with fruits which again I
still don't know what essence means
ten calories this is the most caloric
Seltzer we've had yet
up next Adirondack this immediately I
immediately was brought back to when I
get sick and I get medicines I mean I
feel sick but I think it's for a
different reason I can't work it up next
365 so we are starting with your
favorite flavor yes which is the lack of
flavor next up is vintage 17 left as
you'll see this when you open it it's
gonna be substantial I think you'll
rough mmm you got to be careful
well up next Lacroix only 14 more to go
I always called it the cross because
that's the correct pronunciation but
then I understand it's based on the
river which those locals call McCoy I
guess whatever it doesn't matter alright
hope you're thirsty
oh honey so why is it called compliments
how do you pronounce it problem problem
news
I mean it's French for great
[Music]
it's French I didn't know that oh okay
so it's part of my like Lacroix boy
identity ivory like something I feel
like there's actually that Euler cook
with it i all my eating there mmm
totally right and now the grand finale
Schweppes only four more to taste I am
kind of lukewarm ourselves or because it
makes me gassy
I've waited what feels like years for
this
I feel greasy kind of sweating
ironically on Thirsty's Cheers
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well we're not quite done as promised we
are going to attempt something that has
never been done before we're going to
combine all 70 cell sirs which I just
drink into a big vat and create the
world's first mega seltzer
[Music]
it's a little off light which I don't
love it's kind of like a very pale rosy
there's a lot going on yeah what I don't
hate it it's just weird it's just weird
I see things floating in there it's
perplexing so there you have it we tried
every Seltzer we could get our hands on
we combined every cell sin we could get
our hands on and now now I got a peek
[Music]
[Music]